Um, good afternoon, and this is probably
one of the final sessions before, um,
before Reinvent comes in the close, and
thanks for joining us. I know we've got some lots of competition
today with, uh,
Werner Vogel's keynote, but, uh, I appreciate
your attendance today. Thank you very much.
So my name's Stephen Leedig, I'm a principal solutions
architect, uh, with the surplus team out of
Australia and New Zealand.
Um, and I'm joined today by Archana Shikantha,
who, um, is a principal engineer with the AWS
Lambda team.
And today we want to introduce you to a
new feature that we launched on earlier
this week,
um, called Lambda Managed Instances.
So
AWS has been,
has not just pioneered Servius, um,
but as you can see here,
we've um continually um and rigorously,
um,
Innovated in this space. From the early
beginnings of introducing runtime
like you know Python, um,
types, uh, uh,
Node JS and Java,
we've now and and and for now and
and bringing this to today where
we're virtually um
supporting any type of run time.
To introducing VPC integration,
optimizing network integration through
um hyperplane interfaces,
and also introducing things like layers and
concurrency, and continually optimizing
cold starts
to, you know, help you build the
applications you're building today.
And we've also along the way introduced
some new services, step functions and
Eventbridge to help you
orchestrate millions of workflows and
build event-driven architectures.
And over the last 10 years,
customers have been, you know, really enjoying the
benefits of the, this
really wide portfolio of serverless services,
to help them run and build
modern applications in the cloud today.
And doing that with, you know,
with without having to write or um or
write a lot of less code and focusing
on business logic,
and not getting bogged down by scaling
and security updates and other
maintenance issues.
And only paying for the services
that, um, you know, are driving value for
your organization, um while minimizing
waste. And also being able to take advantage
of the best practices um that
we have for distributed architectures and
security. And
as you can see here, we've got a huge
um diversity in um in
um use cases for errs today.
Um, we've got financial institutions migrating
core banking applications,
um, to AWS leveraging LAMDA
and other AWS services to cut
operational costs and to accelerate future
development.
We're looking at healthcare, um, providers
who've been using LAMDA to automate,
um, appointment bookings,
um, insurance claims processing, and
secure patient portal access.
Retail companies are adopting event-driven
architectures as a way of being
able to innovate quickly and handle
um peak shopping, um, peak shopping
spikes.
And start-up organizations are using Servius
to, you know, keep their costs to net
zero,
especially in the early parts of their growth period,
and then, um being able to iterate on features
quickly. And government agencies
as well, um, are, are leveraging
uh servalus, um,
agencies like the Australian Bureau of Statistics,
who built their last Australian census
entirely on servius.
And yet, despite all of these
successes and all of these, all of this diversity,
um, you know, customers are still telling us we
like the programming model, but there are still some
use cases
for which we need to look at other options.
And that's led them to, um, you know,
significant architectural shifts,
um, and taking on much greater responsibility
from an operations perspective.
And they're asking for more control around
where their um functions are running, and
what they're running on.
And also being able to apply
some of the, you know, um, early commitments
that they and usage discounts that they're making
on other um on other um
compute services.
And looking at multi-concurrency as a way of
um optimizing price and performance
um as well.
So land and managed instances is a solution
to this.
Um, we've got, uh, lender managed
instances allows you to keep the
the same programming model that you're familiar today
and build architectures in the same,
uh, surplus way as well, while maintaining,
uh, a, a consistent and familiar
development experience.
And we're giving you more control over specialized
compute
and extensive choices around
um the the compute that um you
that that your functions are running on.
And also taking advantage of no cold starts.
And in addition to that, we're driving efficiencies
through the um through and
and predictability through ECP
EC2 pricing mechanisms,
while at the same time
giving you an option around multi-concurrency invokes.
So what is lambda managed instances? Fundamentally,
it's the ability for you to run AWS
lambda functions
on EC2 instances of your
choice in your account.
You've got access to over 400
different instance types
across um general purpose compute
optimized,
memory optimized instance family to best
suit your particular workload
needs. And AWS
is still handling all of the operational
elements. We're dealing with the life cycle
uh the appli the the the life cycle of
the instance.
We're managing the operating system,
um, and the runtime patching that is that's built
into those instances.
We're dealing with all the routing and auto scaling
and doing that according to your configurations.
And at the same time, you're benefiting
from the ability to um apply
easy to pricing um constructs like
easy to um savings plans,
compute savings plans, reserved instances,
and any other special agreements that you have with
us. So
the question is now, when do you use
managed instances?
Um So managed
instances is not a um
in place replacement for lander today.
Specifically, you would be looking at using
managed instances
for things like high traffic, steady
state workloads that have um
you know, smooth and predictable traffic patterns.
You'd be looking at
using managed instances for
applications that um have
very specific computational needs
or memory requirements or network
uh throughput requirements.
And for um and for everything else, you
would continue to lose lambda.
Lambda today, or lambda default as we're calling
it, um, is really ideal
for um you know, workloads
with unpredictable traffic.
And where you have short duration
um and um
and and infrequent invocations.
So what we're gonna do today, um, I'm I'm
just gonna walk you through,
um, an experience around how to build out
your lambda managed instances, um,
environment. Um, and we'll talk about some
key differences
between what lambda default provides,
and also what lambda, how lambda managed
instances works.
And then I'll round it off with some part integrations
and information about the developer tooling
that we're supporting, as well as some pricing
information. Over to your channel.
Thank you all right.
Uh, hi everyone. So as Steven mentioned, I'm Arch.
I'm a principal engineer with LAMDA, and
most recently I've been the tech lead on this
project which we're all very excited to bring to you.
Um,
so Steven gave us a really great introduction into
why we built LAMDA managed instances or
LMI as I'm gonna call it for the rest of this talk,
um, and I'm gonna take you on a kind of technical
deep dive into the experience of actually
creating a function on LMI.
And um as we walk through that
experience um I want us to just pay
attention to the ways in which
the LMI experience is actually very
similar and very familiar with the default
lambda experience that you all kind of know and
love today
and then in a subsequent section we'll talk about
the ways in which LMI is different from
from lambda default and how that should inform
your choice of when to use which platform.
All right, so the eventual setup
that we're going for here, like Steven mentioned
is in your customer account
in your VPC
Lambda will launch EC2 instances
and then deploy your function on
those EC2 instances.
Now these EC2 instances are what we
call lambda. Managed instances
and what that means is it's mostly
just a regular EC2 instance except
that it's fully managed by lambda.
We handle the launching of this instance.
We handle the OS patching of these instances,
uh, and the entire life cycle of the instance right
up to the termination of the instance.
What you can do with the instance is you can see
it in your console you can describe
the instance, but you can't touch it in any way,
even if you wanted to, so you can't
update the instance you can't edit the instance you
can't SSH into the instance,
nor can you actually even terminate the instance.
So the entire management of these instances are
completely delegated to lambda,
um,
as the service managing it.
And in terms of billing like Steven mentioned, you know,
regular EC-2 billing applies to these
instances along with any kind of pricing
instruments that you have with EC-2.
Now in terms of these functions that are deployed
on your on your instances it's
what we call um execution
environments and for those of you of you
who are not familiar,
a lambda function execution environment is
basically a live running copy
of your application so it's your function code,
the language run time underneath it, your
layers, your extensions, all of that
that's kind of bootstrapped and up and running,
ready to handle and invoke so that's what
we call a function execution environment.
Alright, so how do you make all this magic happen
in your account?
The experience here involves 3 steps.
And we'll look at each of these steps in detail,
but the first step here is to create a
capacity provider.
This is where you give us all your
instance level configuration and
settings.
And then you create a function
and then you associate it with that capacity
provider that you just created
and then finally you publish a function
version and this is the step that makes
all the magic happen so the the launching of the
instances and the deployment of your function on those
instances.
So let's take a look at each of these in a little
bit deeper detail, starting with the capacity
provider. The capacity
provider is a brand new construct. It's a lambda
construct that we've introduced just for
LMI and like I said, it's
basically all things instances all of
your overrides and settings that you wanna
provide to us in terms of your
instance configuration goes in this capacity
provider object.
And here are some of the settings here.
So the first one is your instance VPC config.
The second one is the actual instance
types that you want us to use,
um, for your functions.
And finally we'll look at,
um, some guard rails that you can put
in terms of how we scale your instances
when the load on your functions goes up.
So let's start with the VPC config.
So here we have our new create capacity
provider API.
The first thing in there is the capacity
provider name. You give it a name. You can put tags
on it,
and then, and then you have to give us a role. So
this is the capacity provider operator role.
So this is just a standard IAM role
where you're giving lambda permissions to actually
launch and manage those EC2 instances
in your account.
And then we come to the VPC config. This
is standard VPC config subnets and
security groups,
and this is the VPC that will launch
your instances into.
Now in terms of required
parameters
this is all you really need to create
a capacity provider.
Now there's a whole bunch of other settings which
we're gonna talk about, but just know
that those are all
kind of they all have defaults they're advanced
settings for the power users who really
wanna kind of fine tune the capacity that's
that's underneath your functions,
but in terms of required parameters,
that's all you need. You need a role and you need a VPC
and you need to give that to us.
In terms of the subnets that you give
us in your VPC config,
um, you know, if it is a prod application,
the standard kind of guidance, AWS
guidance applies.
Give us subnets in 3 availability zones
because when you do that we will actually
spread the instances that we launch and
thus the execution environments across
those availability zones evenly.
In terms of networking.
These are just regular EC2 instances,
so they have a primary network interface
in your VPC, which means they get an IP
address from your VPC
and all of the outbound traffic
from your function execution environments
actually transits through this
network interface of the instance.
So if your function wants to talk to any
downstream dependencies, make sure that
you have a path through your,
uh, capacity provider VPC
to those endpoints of those dependencies.
Also, the, the application logs
that we ship uh to CloudWatch,
those logs also transit through
this network interface of the instance.
So another thing you wanna remember and
make sure is that you actually have a path to the
cloud watch endpoint
through your your VPC.
You can do this by either
allowing Internet access to hit the public endpoint
or you can use a private link cloud watch
endpoint within your VPC,
but just remember that all your logs are also
transiting through
this instance VPC.
And then in terms of ingress traffic
this is um the same as is true
of lambda default functions today
uh there is no ingress traffic that's
coming in through
that network interface to your instance
or your execution environment so you can go
ahead and kind of close all those inbound
rules on the security groups that that you give us,
right? All
right, the other thing about VPC configuration is
because all of the egress traffic from your functions
is going through the instances network,
um, we actually do not allow
you to specify a VPC config
at the function level. So in the create function API,
if you're creating an LMI function,
um, you cannot provide a VPC config.
We'll always just use the VPC config that you
provide in your capacity provider.
All right, let's talk instance types.
So the full set of instance
types that is supported on LMI
is basically these latest generation
C, M, and R instance
families. So C is the compute optimized
DC2 instance family,
uh, M is general purpose, and R is
memory optimized.
And in terms of sizes we support the
dot large instance sizes and, and
bigger within these families.
And um in terms of architectures
we support both Intel and AMD
for X86 and then we also
support the ARM graviton instance types.
Now within this kind of large set of
instance types that we support
by default
lambda will select the instance types
for your function
based on your functions, memory size
and configuration, and we'll talk a little bit more
about that when we get to the function section.
But
you can always override
if you want to constrain the set of
instance types that we use some more like
not use this entire set
you can do that via an override
and that's where we come to this instance requirements
section within the capacity provider
here you can specify
uh allowed instance types which is only use
these instance types or you can specify
excluded instance types which is saying you
know use
everything else but these.
And then a few other settings in here, um,
architecture by default we assume it's an X86
application, uh, you have to overwrite it for ARM.
The other thing is to remember that your architecture
of your function matches the architecture of your
capacity provider.
And finally for the
um
EBS volumes that are attached
to your instances
by default they're encrypted with a service
managed key
uh here you can provide your own KMS
key that we we can use to to encrypt the EBS
volumes.
All right, um, scaling, so we
have a, we have a,
a pretty deep dive into scaling, um,
a few sections later,
uh, and we'll talk about some of the more advanced scaling
configurations there,
but here I just wanted to introduce that
there is a capacity provider scaling config
section, so this is all instance level scaling
here that we're talking about,
um, and the first setting there is a max VCPU
count. Uh, this is basically
a limit on the.
The maximum instance capacity that we
can scale out to uh as the load
increases within your capacity provider,
um, it's mostly useful as a cost control
knob so you can put kind of a hard
limit on the kind of instance billing
that can occur from a given capacity
provider
again optional setting, uh, we have defaults
you can override it only if you have a need to.
Yeah, and like I said, there's a, there's more settings in
here which we'll talk about in the context of the
scaling section.
All right, so now you have a capacity provider.
Your next step is to create a function,
and this is where kind of the, the
familiar lambda experience kicks in.
The, the process to create a function is
almost exactly the same thing as you would
go through today.
With the only little change is that when you're creating
a function you have to associate it with this
capacity provider that you just created,
which is what lets us know that this is an LMI
function and it needs to be deployed on your
instances as opposed to a default lambda
function that goes on our infrastructure.
Um, and then we'll just talk about some of the function
features that are supported with LMI,
um, and finally we'll,
uh, talk about the function
memory and CPU settings
and how that influences the, the instance
type that we select underneath
those functions.
All right.
So this is our
good old familiar create function API
and in here we have a new section
for the capacity provider config
and that's where you provide the capacity
provider R and it's just as simple as
that to make it an LMI function.
And uh you can associate
multiple functions with the same
capacity provider,
in which case all of those functions will
share the same instance capacity
um
within that capacity provider.
All right, moving on to function features
that are supported,
um.
Packaging formats, we support both
OCI containers and zip
format,
language runtime,
latest versions of Java, Python,
Node, and .NET.
So in addition to OS patching that's
happening at the instance level, you continue to
get the benefit of like the actual language run
time is being managed and patched by lambda
as well so that's the same familiar experience.
Uh, other features that we support in terms
of kind of
the observability space layers and
extensions are supported with LMI
in terms of invoke kind of dynamics
function URLs you can use with LMI response streaming
works with LMI.
Um
The invoked timeout is 15 minutes, which
is the same as, uh, default
functions today.
Um,
but finally we did announce, uh, another
big launch from Lambda was durable functions
which allows you to run
longer running functions,
um,
that can tolerate interruptions and kind
of multi-step applications and
that also works with LMI.
In terms of some things that are
not supported or not applicable I should
say to LMI,
uh, Snapstart is one that is
not applicable to LMI
because there are actually no cold starts in
LMI and we'll talk a little bit more about
that in the scaling section, but because we don't
have cold
cold starts,
uh, snapstart is not meaningful in LMI.
And, uh, provision and reserved concurrency,
um, these are, are not supported
with LMI because basically we have,
um, equally valent concepts in LMI
by means of min and max execution environments
again this is something we'll see when we talk about
scaling.
All right, so let's talk about function
settings now.
Um, as most of you are familiar,
uh, the create function has a memory
size setting where you tell us how much memory your
functions execution environments should get.
Um, in terms of the ranges, the range
has gone up higher for LMI,
uh, so we do support up to 32
gigs of memory size for your LMI
functions.
And then another new setting that we've
introduced for LMI is this execution
environment memory per VCPU. So
this is basically a ratio of memory
to VCPU for your functions execution
environments.
So based on your memory and this ratio
we will extrapolate how much CPU needs to be allocated.
Um, the default is 2 to 1,
so, uh, 2 gigs
per per VCPU,
uh, and it can go up to 4 to 1
or 8 to 1 are the allowed values
there. Um,
so applying those ratios and the memory settings,
this is kind of the table of all combinations
that we allow.
One thing to note here
is that we don't allow fractional VCPUs,
so, uh, depending on the ratio
that you're using, your memory will kind of jump
in multiples of the ratios if you're using 8
to 1, you can only have memory that's in multiples
of 8. If you're using 4 to 1, you can only have
memory that's multiples of 4.
And then in terms of instance type selection,
these ratios that we have, they basically
match the family, the
instance family ratios that we have up there.
So if, if you're doing a 2 to 1 kind
of ratio,
uh, function,
then that's when we'll select the, the compute,
uh, optimized instance types. If you're
on the other end of the spectrum and you're doing an 8
to 1 ratio,
then we'll select the memory optimized instance
types underneath your
function, and 4 to 1 is the general purpose,
um, instance types.
All right, so now we have a capacity provider
we have a function that's designated
as an LMI function,
but there's still no instances
or execution environments in your in your
account yet.
All of that magic happens when you actually
publish a function version.
Which is what actually triggers the deployment in
this case.
So publishing a function version is actually
a functionality again that exists today.
Uh, it's not required
for lambda default functions so the only
change here is with LMI functions you have to
publish a version to actually deploy it.
Um, but there's, there's two ways
you can do that. You can either use the existing published
version API
or we actually have a little bit of
syn syntactic sugar in the create and
update function API where you can just
set a flag to be true, the publish
flag to be true,
and then every create and update will automatically
publish a version for you behind the scenes.
So it's when you publish this version that's when all
the action starts happening in your account.
And we'll take a look at what that deployment looks
like and then we'll also take a look at the function
level scaling configuration.
All right, so
when you call published version, the first thing
we'll do is we'll actually
map your function to the instance type that's
appropriate for it. We'll launch those EC2
instances in your account,
and on those EC2 instances
we'll actually go ahead and initialize,
um,
by default 3 execution environments
on those instances. We'll launch 3 instances
in 3 availability zones if you've
given us 3
and and initialize 3 execution
environments on them.
And until until the
initialization is complete, your function is
actually in a pending state and only
after it goes active can you
actually start invoking
your function,
all right?
Now these, these 3 execution environments
that come up as part of your function activation,
uh, we call them min execution environments
it's 3 by default, but of
course, um, you can always overwrite
them which comes to our function
scaling config section.
So this is
yet another new API for you
to override some function level scaling
parameters.
This is the put function scaling configuration
API.
Here you have min and max execution
environments which is bounding
at the function level how many execution
environments we can scale in and out.
In terms of min, like we said, the default
is 3,
some, some, some kind of reasons why
you might wanna override these some min, if you
wanna get,
uh, if you wanna pre-provision capacity
for like a known peak or a known
known incoming demand or a buffer,
you can set your min to be higher and we'll always
keep those execution environments warm and up
and running. Um, on the other
hand, you, you can override it lower if
you don't care for having 3,
execution environments up and running and for that kind
of high availability stance if you're using
dev or test workloads you can override that
to be lower.
In terms of max execution environments,
uh, by default there is no max, so
we're basically allowed to scale as much as we
need to,
um,
you can override it for
fair sharing between multiple functions
that are mapped to the same capacity provider.
So like I said, if you have multiple functions
in the same capacity provider, they share the
instance capacity within that capacity provider
so you can cap how much each
can scale to,
um, to kind of prevent noisy neighbor
disturbance.
So this is what I was saying. So these are kind
of equivalent to the provision
capacity reserve uh provision concurrency
reserve concurrency model that we have with on
demand. We're just doing it slightly differently here
for LMI.
And,
finally, uh, another small trick here,
um, you can set your
min and max to 0,
and what that will do is that will basically
cause your function to completely descale
and scale down within your capacity provider.
It is in a deactivated state
at that point, so invokes won't go
through, um,
so you'll have to come back and set min and max to
something greater than 0 for us to scale it
back up and allow those invokes to go
through. So it's just a way for you to.
Basically deactivate the function. So if you're going home
at night, um, you know, for your dev
test workloads, you don't have to actually delete the function.
You can scale it down and then when you come back in the
morning you can scale it back up, right?
All right, so
you know you created a capacity provider, you created
a function,
you published the version we did the deployment
on your instances and now you're ready to invoke
and the the beauty of this feature
is that your invoke experience is
exactly the same as what it is today.
Um, so when your invoke
comes to us we will check if your function is
an LMI function, if it has that capacity
provider associated with it,
and if it does, then we will just route
all of your invokes to these, these
function and, uh, execution environments that we've
deployed on your instances.
And because the invoke experience is
exactly the same,
you actually get all of the event
source integrations that are supported with Lambda
today just work out of the box
just the same with your LMI functions,
um, including kind of the, uh,
the, the different invoke types that we have.
We have the direct invoke or synchronous
invoke as we call it. We also support the event
invocation type and all of
this whole slew of event
integrations work just as is.
So you know we saw how the the
the create function and the invoke experience
basically we
we've retained that as close
closely as possible with the the lambda
default experience
but with just a few extra clicks and a few
extra steps with the capacity provider
we've effectively completely
changed the infrastructure underneath
your functions from service owned infrastructure
to just regular good old EC2
instances in your account.
And because of that kind of big
capacity shift underneath your functions
there are some differences
between lambda default and LMI in terms of
the the management of the capacity
underneath
um
that you should be aware of.
When you're using LMI,
so let's take a look at those.
The first one here is concurrency.
I'm sure for for those of you who've used
lambda before, you're probably intimately
familiar with the concurrency
of lambda
default functions.
Uh, concurrency has a slightly different
meaning in the context of LMI,
and Steven briefly mentioned that we do, um,
support multi-concurrent functions in
LMI, so we'll take a look at that here.
The second one is scaling.
Uh, this is another thing that Steven mentioned is that
we don't have any cold starts
in LMI,
so we do scaling in a slightly different way
in LMI, and we'll, we'll take a deeper look at
that and understand how scaling happens in LMI.
And finally, um, the
security boundary.
With, uh, with lambda default
you're running in in our service
account it's a fully multi-tenant set up
here with, uh, LMI
you're gonna be running in your account which is
a fully kind of single tenant set up so
the boundaries are a little bit different there in
terms of security and we'll, we'll talk about that.
All right, let's start with concurrency.
Before we dive into LMI, let's recap a little
bit about what concurrency means for
um lambda default.
So in lambda default when you have a function.
You see an invoke come in
um if we don't have any execution environments
for your function yet,
what we will do is in the path of the
invoke we will say ah there's no execution
environment we'll initialize a new execution
environment and then execute your
invoke within that execution environment.
Now while that invoke is ongoing,
if we get a 2nd invoke, we'll say, oh
that execution environment one is busy,
and what that will do is it'll initialize a
second execution environment within which your 2nd
invoke will execute.
Now these invokes that.
Cause the initialization of
new execution environments,
um, we call them cold starts and they incur
slightly higher latency because we have to actually
uh run your initialization logic
uh as part of kind of the the synchronous
invoke request path, right?
Now this invoke number 3,
it comes in after invoke
1 has completed.
So what happens with invoke 3 is
we actually keep execution environment
1 around in the hope that you'll
send us more invokes.
So with invoke 3 we can just route it to
a pre-existing execution environment and
we don't have to pay the cost of that initialization
and this is what we call warm invokes
and everyone loves warm invokes because they're
super fast and they, they don't incur that latency
cost of the in it.
So the thing to notice here
is that in lambda default
these execution environments are all what we call
singly concurrent,
which means that
um there's only ever one invoke
being executed out of a given execution
environment at a time.
It may get reused for multiple invokes
later in time, but at a given time only
one invoke is active per execution environment.
So when we say concurrency
in lambda default, what that really means it's
just the number of active in-flight invokes
or the number of of active execution
environments that are serving in those those in-flight
invokes that's what concurrency means in lambda
on demand.
In LMI
things are a little bit different, so here we have
3 execution environments that we talked about that
were pre-initialized when you published your version.
And then when your invokes start to come in
an LMI will actually send we can send
multiple concurrent invokes to a
single execution environment
and this is what we call multi-concurrency
single execution environment can be
handling multiple invokes simultaneously.
And um
And this is why we, we don't have cold
starts because we've pre-initialized these execution
environments as part of your function activation.
So when the invokes come in they will always
get routed to one of these execution environments
that we've pre-initialized.
So no cold starts in LMI.
So the first question here is
how do you know how much
concurrency or how much multi concurrency
can you send to each execution
environment?
Now we came up with some defaults
for the maximum concurrency that an
execution environment can take
based on the language
just after researching all the
applications that you all have built on lambda and
other kind of serverless
um
products in our our suite,
uh, we looked at all of the workloads and these are
kind of the defaults that we came up with.
But you can always override it and
this is in our create function
API in that new capacity
provider config section
you can also specify a per execution
environment environment max concurrency
so this is if you have certain bottlenecks that
we're not aware of in terms of your dependencies
or anything like that, you can come in here
and override what's the max concurrency
and execution environment can take.
Now we, we also
realized that it's not
easy to come up with this magic
max concurrency number and there is
no one size fits all,
uh, so we have some protections
here in place in case you set that
max concurrency number to be too high.
So let's take a look at how that works.
So here you have your managed DC2
instances with a few execution environments deployed
on it. And
um also on these instances sitting
in front of your execution environments is an
agent that we deploy
we're calling it the LMI agent here
and this agent also acts as a proxy
to the to your execution environments
when the invokes come in.
So when the invokes come into our service,
we will try to kind of balance the load
evenly across all the execution environments
that you have. We'll pick an execution
environment and we'll route it to this LMI agent
on that instance.
Now if that this execution environment
has either reached the max con concurrency
that you've configured
or if it's running even
before it reaches the max concurrency, if
it starts running into high mem uh
resource pressure
either memory pressure or CPU
pressure,
then our LMI agent will say
hey back off this thing is in is is
running hot go try somewhere else
and then we will reroute your invoke
to a different execution environment.
Now if all if all
of these execution environments kind of
start to heat up and everybody's is telling
us to back off,
then we'll actually just come back to you and throttle
your invoke uh back
and we do this like I said for
for what I call good put protection.
So this is we don't wanna just blindly
send invoke traffic
all the way through to your execution
environments
until you hit this kind of max magic
max concurrency number and actually brown
out or crash all of your execution environments
and you have a full kind of outage of your app.
So we're measuring and seeing how your execution
environments are doing and if it starts to
get to a point where we think it's gonna brown out,
we'll start rejecting some traffic so
that at least you can make forward progress with
the with the capacity that you have, right?
In terms of metrics, if this starts happening,
um, we have new cloud watch
metrics,
uh, for the exact reason that you got
throttled in the bottlenecked resource,
um, so you can get throttled because of your max
concurrency, that's concurrency throttles, CPU
throttles, memory disk, what was the bottleneck
resource that caused those throttles.
And another thing about multi-concurrency
before we move to the next section
is because your execution environments
are handling multiple invokes
simultaneously.
Um, it is important for you
to realize that you need to have these
threat safety best practices,
um, in mind as you
code and develop your application. So this is
again something that's different from lambda,
uh, default where you have singly concurrent,
um, execution environments
here thread safety best practices,
you know, avoid
mutating any shared objects or
global objects when you have multiple
invokes running at the same time.
Uh, use thread local storage and
thread-safe storage for your,
your data structures,
um.
Any shared clients or connections
that you're initializing,
uh, make sure that the configuration on those
are immutable,
uh, in the invoke itself and
also writing to disk,
um, you need to remember if multiple invokes
are writing to disk at the same time they can
clobber on top of each other
so use request specific file
names for any, any rights you're doing to slash
10. All
right, so that was concurrency.
So let's talk about scaling.
So again let's recap what scaling
means in lambda default.
Um, in lambda default, the scaling
is just kind of organic. It's
these cold starts this is
that is when we initialize new execution
environments and that's really just how we scale
when you send us your big kind of load of
invokes if, if you're getting a lot of concurrent
invokes, we just naturally scale out
the execution environments uh as
cold starts in the invoke path.
But in LMI,
um, we said we don't have cold starts,
so the question becomes
if all of these existing execution
environments start to hit that point of saturation,
um, how and when do we actually scale up new
execution environments?
And
the scaling in LMI
is actually asynchronous
and resource based scaling. So what this means
is that
we're constantly monitoring again the
resource heat on your execution environments
and when we see that it's starting to get
close to a certain threshold,
that's when we'll, uh, asynchronously
scale up new execution
environments within your capacity provider.
And if that needs new instances we'll do that as
well, so we'll we'll take a look at that here.
So here you have, um, you know,
3 instances with 3 execution
environments.
You have a friendly LMI agent there
and the LMI agent is constantly kind of gathering
CPU usage stats from your execution
environments and your, your instances and,
uh, kind of sending that data over to us.
And we are monitoring the
kind of average um CPU utilization
uh at the capacity provider level but also at
your function level and we're trying to
maintain this target kind of CPU
utilization threshold.
And if you're kind of within
this plus or minus 10% of
that target threshold,
then that's when we call you as you know you're
in steady state, you're happy, there's no scaling
action happening.
If you start to heat up your CPU
and you start to get into that range above
the the the +10%,
that's when we'll start to scale up new execution
environments.
Um, first we'll fill up existing EC2
instances and then if you need more,
we'll launch new EC2
instances and, and deploy more execution
environments on those.
Now
if you have a burst of
traffic
that's
um very spiky and it bursts up
faster than we can react and add these
instances and execution environments
to your capacity provider,
that's when
you can push your CPU utilization into
that kind of good put protection mode
uh where we have to throttle you until we can actually
bring up more instances and more execution
environments uh to meet that that
load, right?
In terms of scale down, it's the opposite.
If you then start to cool down and come below that
-10% mark,
uh, we'll first take, take, uh, scale
down your execution environments and then
we'll decompress and then actually scale, scale
down instances if we can, uh, kind of
pack it back in, right.
And uh in terms of scale down you're always
protected by your min execution environments
that you configure which is 3 by default but
we'll never scale you down
uh below that number even if if
you're seeing no invokes to your
function. Alright,
so the, the question that all of you are probably having is
what is this magic target CPU utilization
threshold?
Um
So this is this is where we come back to that create
capacity provider scaling config and the more
advanced scaling options that I talked about here.
We have a scaling mode that can
be automatic or manual.
If it's automatic, um, that's
basically we are
looking at your load patterns, your scaling patterns,
and automatically tuning that threshold,
um. To be at a good place
for your application
in manual mode you can take
things into your hands into
your control,
and you can manually basically configure
a target CPU
utilization percentage.
In terms of metrics to monitor all
of this fun stuff again these are all new metrics
that we've added for LMI
at the function level we give you
CPU utilization, memory utilization,
so this is kind of aggregated across all
the execution environments for that function.
You can also see the concurrent executions
like where your max limit is versus what
you're actually using
and finally, um, the chart
at the end there is the actual number of execution
environments that we've scaled up to for your function.
And we also have similar metrics out
at the capacity provider level,
um,
so this is if you have multiple functions within the capacity
provider at the instance level
you can look at
memory utilization, CPU utilization, and
then the actual
count of instances that we've launched
within your capacity provider.
All right, so the scaling takeaway
here that I wanted to leave you with, and this is
again something that Steven brought up
is with lambda default,
um, we,
you know, when your functions run on our infrastructure
we are running a very, very
specialized stack that's built on
Firecracker and that is hyper
optimized to handle these kind of.
Spiky sparse bursty workloads,
it's hyper optimized for cold starts. It's
hyper optimized to keep those cold start latencies
down so that we can actually like bring up
a new, uh, kind of lightweight firecracker
VM, um, in the path of your
invoke. Lambda
managed instances on the other hand is actually
built and designed for a different profile of workloads
like Steven was saying this is built
more
for kind of their stable workloads
that have a good baseline of traffic,
uh, and more smoother and predictable workloads,
you know, the whole, the purpose of this feature
is to move away from specialized stacks
that we are using behind the scenes and
to move to more general purpose kind of
easy to instances in your account.
Um,
so the machinery underneath is very
different and that's why the profile of workloads
that are that LMI is suited for is,
is different,
um, from the profile that's suited
for for default.
So the two are really complementary,
um, features of lambda
that you can use together to kind of cover
more of your use cases.
All right, um,
the final section here is the security
boundary.
Like I said, with, uh, Lambda
default, all of your functions are running
in our service account. It's a big multi-tenant
account, um.
And uh in lambda default every every
functions execution environment runs in its own
VM because it's a multi-tenant setup
with LMI,
uh, everything's running in your account,
nothing, no, nobody else's,
um,
code is running in your account it's a single tenant
set up in that sense.
And the security boundary here for LMI
is really the capacity provider,
um, so if you want
VM level isolation
between your
um functions, the way you
would do that is to have separate capacity
providers because
by definition, um.
The instances within your two separate capacity
providers are going to be different. So if you map two
functions to separate capacity providers, they will
be on different VMs in different instances.
Uh, within the EC2 instance,
um,
the function execution environments that we deploy,
uh, they're, they're basically containers, so they're
separated by a container boundary.
Also, if you map multiple
functions to the capacity provider
like I mentioned, um, then
the execution environments from those different functions
can also share the same instances
and again so it's, it's a container boundary
there so the takeaway here really
is if you
want VM level isolation between your
functions, um, map them to
separate capacity providers because that is
the kind of VM level security boundary
in LMI.
All right, with that, um,
I will hand back to Steven
to talk about partner integration
and tooling and pricing.
OK, so that was a really good
introduction into um
into LMI um and I'm just
gonna talk through some of the new partner
integrations that we have um and
introduce you to our launch partners DataDog and
SEI. So Data Dog provides
full observability for lambda managed
instances.
Um, customers can monitor
um key metrics to understand the health
and the utilization of the lambda managed instances,
and customers can also alert on those
metrics.
Um, and any errors and anomalous,
um, behavior, um, that might need
attention. Um, using
the automatically correlated metrics,
logs, and tracers,
um, that span upstream and downstream
services, um, customers
can also investigate and resolve any, um,
any issues.
And for any new instances that get launched,
um,
there, there are, um, trace
support and auto instrumentation,
um, so customers can get automatic trace
propagation simply by adding the
installing the Data Dog, um, extension.
Now SI also supports lambda managed
instances
um through its autonomous
um optimization platform um
that helps improve performance, cost
and reliability of uh the lambda,
EC2 instances and the rest
of the environment.
Um, this gives, um, engineering and
platform teams as well as, uh, fin
ops teams, a single workflow,
um, um, for making
safe, uh, data optimized,
um, decisions.
Um, and their platform automatically scores
lambda managed, uh, lambda functions,
um, to show you which are strong candidates
for moving to lambda managed instances
so you don't have to do the guesswork.
And once you're ready to move,
ZI's co-pilot also lets you
um migrate
uh and configure functions um with a
single click
and it's a simple low friction way of
moving and migrating your functions to lambda
managed instances.
Now AWS app config um
also featured flag um capability
um and and the other dynamic
configuration that comes with that service is
also fully managed, supported by lambda managed
instances.
So by using AWS app config agent
um lambda extension.
As a, as your, um, as your lambda
functions, you can make calling those
feature flags, uh, simpler,
and also the extension itself
includes best practices that simplify
using um AWS app config
um by by reducing costs. And
that cost reduction
uh results from fewer API calls
uh to the AWS app config service
and shorter and also um results in
shorter lambda processing times.
Now, Amazon Cloudwatch Lambda
Insights um also
has uh provides uh 11
click deployment for uh from the lambda
console.
So this allows you to filter uh capacity
providers. It gives you, um, it allows you
to drill down into instance types and
functions, uh. As well as providing
you with 12 key metrics, um,
um, with 1 minute granularity,
that, um, uh, for things like the
maximum and average CPU utilization,
as well as memory utilization statistics.
And this is providing you with a fully integrated
experience to monitor your lambda managed
instances.
Now if you're using power tools for AWS today, uh,
Power tools is um is really a
suite of utilities that help you, um, um,
standardize, um, application development,
um, and support across a number of different,
um, uh, a number of different, um,
uh, use cases, such as observability,
batch processing, um, helps you
with item potency implementations, as well
as, um, dealing with things like feature
flags and data extraction.
And the the power tool suite is
also fully compatible and thread safety,
uh a thread safe um uh and
ready to run on your lab and managed instances.
And of course we've got um full infrastructure
as code support uh through AWS
cloud formation, the surus
application model, and the um AW
the AWS cloud development kit,
as well as our partners Terraform.
And all of those things uh uh all of the, all of that,
all of the APIs that Channa was talking
about are fully supported um within
those um within those frameworks.
Now from a pricing perspective,
um, AWS um sorry, Lambda
Managed instances uses EC EC2
basing uh pricing,
um, with the addition of a 15%
management fee on top of the EC2
instance costs.
Now the price of the instance
itself will largely depend on
um the amount, the discounts that are applied
to those instances. However, the EC2
um management, so the um the management fee
is still based on the default price for the EC2
instance. Now on top of that,
um, you would still be
charged for the um the same
uh cost for per invocation
um that lambda default has today,
uh, with the exception that you're no longer
paying for the uh function duration
costs because everything is running on your
machine. So
to wrap things up, let's have a look at some key takeaways.
As I mentioned earlier,
lambda management instances isn't
designed to be a a replacement for
the lambda that you're uh lambda functions
that you're running on lambda default today.
It's really designed for those specific use
cases
to help you with high traffic and
steady state workloads or where you need
specialized compute options to
run functions um uh for
uh for specific use cases.
For everything else, lambda, um,
lambda uh default, um, provides
you, um, you know, uh, the, the ability
to continue working, uh, running new
applications that have unpredictable traffic,
short duration, or infrequent invocations.
So that's a really key takeaway here.
And also when you've seen what we've,
what we've, when we, when we, when you understand what
we've just done for you is basically we've
allowed you to define your own execution environments.
This is
you running lambda as you do today,
the same experience, you get to maintain
the same programming model, you you
get to maintain the same architecture,
you get to use the same development tools,
but you've got more control over where
and how your functions are running.
And you're also able to apply
all of the cost benefits that you're getting with EC-2
on top of that.
So that's all we have for you today. Um,
we are really interested to see what
you build with land and managed instances um
and look forward to um
to to seeing what you do with that. Thank you very much.